hey what's going on folks there are two
different things I want to discuss in
this video today and both are pertaining
to the television show mostly because
I've been getting a bunch of comments
lately about the wall and whites being
able to cross it which I'm going to
explain very shortly but first I want to
give my prediction about the wall and
the whole Nights Watch in general this
is something I have discussed before but
at the time there was only a few hundred
subscribers so the majority of you do
not know my thoughts on this so I want
to tell you what I think the future of
the Nights Watch is going to be and I
think it's pretty obvious at this point
that the wall is going to come down
everyone that was living north of the
wall has either came south with John or
they were killed and turned into whites
we know that Craster is no longer alive
to supply the night's king with babies
to turn in the White Walkers and all the
wildlings and other tribes have been
killed as well so there's no longer any
purpose for the night's king and his
army to stay north he is now going to
come south to complete whatever this
mission of his may be and there are
several ways that they could actually
pass through the wall during a vision
bran was marked by the night's king
which allows the night's king to follow
bran wherever he goes and enter any
where he may be hiding even if there was
magic to keep him out the mark on his
arm now allows him and his men to pass
through it so this may have the exact
same effect with the wall when Uncle
Benjen dropped the brain and mirror off
outside of the wall he made it a point
to let brand know that the wall had
magic woven into it when it was built to
keep the others out including Uncle
Benjen in considering we just saw the
magic at the three-eyed Ravens cave get
deactivated because of the Marquand
brand this may have been a hint that if
bran crosses the wall then he is going
to deactivate it there as well but there
has also been speculation that the
night's king could have a horn that can
actually knock down the wall or at least
deactivate the magic in it which would
allow him and his men to cross through
and another way could possibly be by an
ice dragon some people think there may
be an ice dragon hiding inside of the
wall
or the night's king could potentially
kill one of Daenerys dragons and then
use it to knock down the wall in some
way
I actually think either one of these
things are possible the ice dragon
inside of the wall is probably the least
likely to happen but it's still a
possibility nevertheless but regardless
of how he does it the night's king and
his men will be south of the wall during
season eight and out of all the castles
guarding the wall only three of them are
active but in the television show the
main focal point has been on Castle
black which lies dead center on the wall
and I think when the night's king and
his men attack this is going to be where
they strike first the Nights Watch and
most importantly Castle black right now
is our first line of defense whenever
there is an attack on the wall that can
potentially threaten the realm the
Nights Watch is what protects us from
any kind of breach on the wall only this
time there will be nothing that they can
do to stop it
the Nights Watch are low on men they
probably have less than 100 men at
Castle black right now and every time
they have asked for help it has fallen
on deaf ears no one takes the threat
seriously nor do they really respect the
protection that the Nights Watch
provides which is going to be something
those southerners are going to regret
because when the night's king gets
through the wall the Nights Watch is
going to be completely decimated we may
even see a 20-ton piece of ice just come
crashing down on a Castle black and what
little men they do have there will not
stand a chance to what's coming for them
not only will they be outnumbered by the
whites but there isn't one person at the
wall right now that has any Valyrian
steel or dragonglass to use against the
White Walkers who have shown that they
are very athletic with superhuman powers
the 50 or so men at Castle black will be
cut through like a hot knife through
butter and eventually turned into whites
that's right that's exactly what I
think's going to happen we're going to
see the men guarding the wall turned
into whites and I kind of had this
feeling that the entire wall was going
to come down not just a section of it
but they may actually do this
differently in the show because it would
cost a lot of money for CGI to show a
wall of this size come completely
crashing down but in the books where it
costs no money to make these things
happen on a page
I feel that the night's king will bring
down the entire wall that way they can't
be easily pushed back north and the wall
easily be fixed again to keep them out
but there is actually one good thing in
the end when this final war is over with
the night's king there will no longer be
a need for the wall or the Nights Watch
I do not think they're going to risk
trying to make another pact with the
night's king
I think the night's king and his men
will be completely defeated and now that
all the wildlings and other tribes are
already south or dead they will no
longer need any protection up north all
of the threats that were once beyond the
wall will cease to exist so there will
no longer be a need for a Night's Watch
up there in the end I don't think the
punishment is going to be dealt with the
same way either people wouldn't be sent
to the wall anymore for the rest of
their lives just for stealing a block of
cheese the entire way of life is going
to be changed and that's how I see the
future of the Nights Watch in the wall
ending there will no longer be a purpose
for it or a need for it not after this
war is over but there's something else I
want to discuss something that has been
a hot topic as of lately and I'm
assuming most of you I've heard the plot
leaked and most of you know that I give
spoiler updates whenever reports or
photos are released pertaining to
certain themes that are being filmed as
game of thrones produces its seventh
season well one part of the plot lake
states that Jon Snow and a few other
characters are going to go north of the
wall to capture a wight that way Jon can
bring it south to show it to everyone
that way he can prove that there is a
threat beyond the wall and every time
new photos are released as they film it
seems to be confirming that this is
actually going to take place and I've
gotten dozens and dozens of comments
about this scene
most people are wondering how this is
possible because as far as we know
White's cannot pass through the wall but
first I just want to say I think there's
one important thing we need to keep in
mind whenever we talk about this plot
leak we have to realize that we are
reading everything out of context we
have no idea how they are going to set
these scenes up so when we read the plot
leaked and read one sentence that is
meant to be an entire scene
we really can't assume that they're
going to do these things without
explaining how it's taking place I think
they may have actually written something
really smart and logical which is going
to explain how John does take a white
through the wall but we're never really
going to know by just reading this one
sentence so I think it's only fair to
wait until we see how it actually plays
out before we criticize it too harshly
myself included because I didn't think
it was right either but Brian may
actually cross through the wall and
deactivate the magic which might allow
John to take the white through the wall
and there is also a legend that is known
that no man can pass through the wall
unless they're with a member of the
Nights Watch
I think it's said along the lines of
once someone joins the watch and takes
their vows they can now pass through the
wall and whoever was with them can pass
through it too so if you think about it
every time someone crosses the wall in
the show they were actually with a
member of the Nights Watch John was with
the wildlings one day crossed and Sam
was with bran mirror Jojen and Hodor
when they crossed the only other time in
the show when someone got to the other
side they either climbed the wall like
John and the wildlings did or they
sailed around it like Stannis and Davos
did which might explain how the other
two White's got through the wall a few
seasons back when the one white attacked
Lord Commander Mormont and I know most
people think those weren't white just
yet but I actually think they were
White's the entire time I think the
night's king just deactivated them and
had them play possum until the right
time it's really no different than the
Trojan horse really remember how Sam
mentioned that there was no smell to
them that the dead body should have
stunk they pointed that out for a reason
I believe I think that's because they
were already white they weren't fully
dead
they weren't preserved because of the
cold or else they would have never had
Sam say it like that
so when Jon gets to the wall with the
white to bring south once the new Lord
Commander opens the gate and greets Jon
from returning from his mission this may
be how the white is able to enter
through the wall I think they can pass
with a member of the Nights Watch I
don't know that for a fact
but this is just one way that they could
actually explain it Benjy knows he can't
cross by himself because he had the
dragonglass plunged into his chest but
he doesn't know that they already have
brought whites through the gate mend at
the night's king left his bait that way
he could get someone inside the wall
without raising any suspicion I think
the fact that they were regular human
bodies allowed them to pass also they
don't have nearly as much magic in them
as the night's king and White Walkers do
so I think if Jon brings a weight to the
wall that has the human body still and
he walks through the gate with a member
of the Nights Watch especially if it's
the Lord Commander I actually think it's
possible we may just have to suspend
disbelief with this one but I'm thinking
it will be explained in some way during
the episode unless bran removes the
magic by crossing then all bets are off
but I still have no idea how they're
going to pull this off I just wanted to
throw some things out there and see what
you guys think about it maybe together
in the comment section we can use this
plus whatever other ideas you guys may
have and come up with a better solution
so comment below and let me know what
you guys think and as always I
appreciate all you guys taking the time
to listen and watch this even if you do
disagree with me we can still have a
friendly debate about it
so if you guys don't mind do me a favor
and hit that like button and I will see
you guys in the comments section thank
you guys bye